You know, I really like that chapter. I mean, I think that chapter is so interesting, and there's
so much going on there, but uh, and I've never been too enamored of the schizophrenic, um
I don't want to say metaphorics, but metaphorics in Anti-Oedipus and whatnot, and you know, it just
it just seems to me like it causes way more trouble, um, than it's worth in terms of the
history of the reception of the stuff, because you have to have that same conversation all the time
like we're not talking about the disease of schizophrenia, or nor trying to romanticize it,
which is often the accusation, you know, but but but this one I liked. I mean, especially because it was
just like, well, frankly, there are two kinds of nonsense, right? Like, I mean, the the simplest way
of saying it is like not all nonsense is equally interesting nonsense, you know, so that I mean, I
loved reading the the Artaud stuff on Carrol is hilarious. Like, I think I laughed out loud about
that. He just sounds like a priggish little whatever the quote was, and I was like, yeah, he does that
actually gives it that actually describes quite well my experience in reading Alice in Wonderland a few
weeks ago of like, yeah, this just sounds like a stuffy little shithead. There are in Jabberwocky
passages of facality, but it is the facality of an English snob who curls the obscene within himself
like ringlets of hair around a curling iron. That that was it. It was that like ringlets of hair
that was to me, I was like, that's ingenious, right? That's fantastic. Yeah, exactly. Oh, my little fecal
better, you know, and I'm like, yeah, that is that is how it feels, and it's, I mean, I don't know, as a kid
I never liked Alice in Wonderland. Like, I never liked it. It never appealed to me as a kid, so the
sort of sheer kid perspective, and it always seemed like kind of standoffishly creepy to me, right? Like
it, oh, as a kid, I'm just saying my perspective as a young child when exposed to Alice in Wonderland, I
just always had this bad vibe, uh, and you know, you get it, you can't not get exposed to it, right? So I
mean, I, and I don't remember the specific circumstances because I was young, but I always just was like, ew
ew was always my reaction to it. I enjoyed it more rereading it, you know, a few weeks ago or whatever,
like that was it, it was like there's more interesting here, but I still had that. I still had that vibe
right, and and I was like, Artaud captures it, which is maybe a problem for me when Artaud captures a
sense that I'm after
I mean, I don't know if there are two kinds of nonsense so much. I mean, can we talk about them in
terms of like a breaking point of intensities of nonsense, right? That's fine. Yeah, that's fine.
I mean, because it seems like, you know, especially in the language of Artaud is to think about being
as pure nonsense, and you know, I mean, I I think of of, you know, like the Apollonian dimension and
in Nietzsche's writing of of like, look at the schizophrenic is the one that's able to contend
with the the mass, the Dionistic mass of being, and it is terrifying, and it's only through sort of
like the dream-like spacing or the interjection of a certain kind of controlled nonsense that creates a livable
world, and so like we're the dreamers, schizophrenics woke up and found themselves clinging to the back of that tiger
right? Scary fuck, yeah, right? Yeah, I think I went into reading this chapter being wicked excited because I was like,
oh, this is where we're gonna figure out that there is like kind of a bad nonsense, like there is kind of a nonsense that is too too nonsensical, right? Um, but
actually I think I learned more about sense and the fragility of the surface than I did about
some other kind of nonsense. Well, the first line, nothing is more fragile in the surface
right, and and it's specifically because I think of of the addition of of just everything that bodies can
do in that encounter, right? Like all of the all of the depth of bodies, you know, that's going to
potentially be kind of destructive and violent
it's also I mean let me just say this, I mean I think one of the things that did strike me when I read this
was like this is a sort of paradigm case for
what Deleuze does when he reads, right? Like, in the sense of a diagnostics, right? Like that you know
you think of the the title of the collection, which I think is a great title, and Dan Smith has a fantastic essay at the beginning of it, but
essays critical and clinical, you know, and clinical in the sense of he does he sees literary authors
as diagnosing ways of being in the world, right? And and that's what he's really doing here. I mean
it's it's it's really interesting because there was a point at which when when when he goes to the Artaud
and obviously knowing something about how much how much interest he has in Artaud, right? Like that that Artaud is
in many ways a kind of heroic figure for
Schizoanalysis in in in Anti-Oedipus for sure and throughout throughout the work, so I kind of anticipated that
he was going to like beat up on Lewis Carroll as a result, like now is the part of the book like Lewis
Carroll got us into nonsense but Artaud is going to take us home, right? And he didn't do that, right?
Like it just became it became instead just a diagnosis of a differential relation to it and I and I was
really, I was quite, I mean I was pleased by that, but I was also like intrigued by it because you know
it's that moment where you're like he could have uh made and I thought he was going to make a certain
kind of move and he didn't make it and instead it was just okay uh so Artaud is himself doing a diagnosis
and what can we learn what can we diagnose from Artaud's attempt at diagnosing Carroll
about Artaud and it really is this kind of like I don't know I mean just it returns me at the the
larger point to that style question it's just like just different ways of living right and
what do they indicate like what are what are the components of them to the point where
you know like how they break up words right like I mean there's there's a whole page in there of like
pretty meticulous um analysis that I mean I frankly I don't know if I could benefit from
slowly reading that because it's just like okay this is a very idiosyncratic Deleuzian
um approach this I don't really get what he's saying at all of those at most of the points you
know but I do get what he's doing which he's saying how you explode words right or or fuck with words
right let's just say how you experiment with words matters right and it and it indicates different
relationships so that Carroll's is a relationship to meaning whereas you know Artaud's is a relationship to
language right and those are different components of the language of the language game and I I just
really I I just found this like man this is a really great example of I just I wish like literary
critics would read things like this I would just be really curious like a good literary critic right like
what would they think of the way that Deleuze reads this not not his conclusions I don't care about
that but like the way of engaging the question of Artaud's writing and Carroll's writing you know I don't
know well I think describing uh this sort of diagnostic in terms of a differential relationship as opposed to
like just sort of like a taxonomical survey of the field which is to say it's not just like hey here's
Carroll's way of diagnosing emotive being here's Artaud's and here are the differences i.e. like I mean
where difference is reduced to the same it's yeah what's what's yeah to identities what's interesting
here is how important uh Artaud's diagnosis of of um Carroll is because of the way that um the entire like
carol's entire apparatus sort of slides into our toes and then affects that artoian body you know and
it's not just through through the sort of like disgust that he has for Carroll as the the producer of these
texts but I mean you can also see a whole lot of evidence of the way that Carroll's system sort of
like affects Artaud uh sensually I mean like it seems painful right it seems sure you know you can
imagine that yeah that you know this thing that Carroll crafts to ostensibly do one kind of thing slides
into this Artaudian machine it becomes incredibly violent as it operates at the level of of you
know it suddenly creates these chasms at the level of the surface and now creates these violent painful
riffs of like riffs and and that's I mean that's another thing that's cool is like it doesn't rely
it doesn't simply stay at the general level that you began with there of saying
our toe and carol are different right like like or even our toe thinks carol sucks right like i mean
it's like okay I mean that that to me is always the more interesting question why does Artaud what's
going on that Artaud has this response as opposed to just that he has the response and that we agree
with Artaud or we don't agree with Artaud or we defend Carroll or in other words this is where to me
argumentation as we generally conceive of it is so boring right like it because it always stays in that
terrain and that's where the that kind of diagnostic um or I mean I would call it experimental diagnostic
work is so much more interesting and so much more after the sort of what's what it's after is
is the singularity like what the fuck is going on here like what's going on that that's you know
these two people that I have admiration for one reads the other and experiences physical pain
or at least writes that he experiences physical pain what's happening there that physical pain is not
just a more extravagant expression of dislike you know so like let's take him seriously when he says
these things you know and and I just I love the kind of at least to me there's such a care
uh in involved and I just don't read that and I I would say you know I I mentioned a moment ago
The sort of literary criticism example, but the little bit that I've toured through rhetorical criticism
It's just absolutely obtuse on that. Like, it just doesn't, it doesn't ever, you know, to me rhetorical
criticism is always in the service of an argument, or at least the stuff that I've read, right? Like, is
always in the service of an argumentative point, so it never gets into what I'm calling that sort of
care, caring attentiveness of like what's what's going on here, that this person reads this way or or
responds this way, you know. Well, I mean, with argumentation tends to prefigure the argument and
then focuses most of his concentration on like substantiating and supporting that argument or
tearing it down, but it always sort of presents the argument itself as an identity or a content that
is predefined and is always just more or less correct or stronger or weaker.
Yeah, there's so much more vulnerability in the diagnostic or curiosity. I mean, this is where you
know, this is one of the questions, I mean, you know, we can bring it to the level of doxa, but this is one
of the things that interested me in terms of like Caddy's project when when I met you whatever a few years
ago or whatever, and I was, you know, like, um, how do you not make an argument for against doxa? And I
don't think you're doing that, by the way, and I think that's one of the things that's most drawn
me to the things that you're doing was I was like because I think I had this background skepticism that
she, you know, everybody hates doxa, right? Like, doxa is, you know, opinion, belief, and and nobody's like
hey go opinion except for the demagogues, right? Um, so and nobody likes them so whatever. So I was you
know, and but but everything I read of yours, you're not doing that, right? You're not just like, hey, I'm
trying to save doxa from its from its ill repute. It's kind of like how does this thing work, right? And
there is and I read it in in the sort of what I would call like the disposition, the style of the
analysis here, that the moments, the number of moments where I think he's going to make an argumentative
move and he doesn't do it, right? That there is that kind of care, what I'm calling, I mean, whatever you
call, but it's also a sort of vulnerability and it's a sort of willingness to like okay well let's
then ask the next question, right? Like what does this indicate and okay so maybe it's this
and all the while he's he's configuring a what we would loosely call a theory of sense meaning
that the notion of sense is getting um re-articulated, complicated, um, I wouldn't simply
say developed. It's not simply like an expansive increase. It's actually just like in the case
of the schizophrenic chapter for example it's very it's very clear to me that there's just a deviation
of a line that goes on here like if there has been development so far it's not it doesn't continue
to expand it just goes oh there's another you know offshoot over here and so it's just a really
interesting way of thinking about theory, right? Or theorizing or the things that you know the three
of us allegedly. I mean, I think that we could see a parallel between what he's doing in this chapter
and seeing the intersection between Artaud and Carroll and what you just described as sort of like the
the the production of a theory of sense in this book called The Logic of Sense and is that in both
cases he's avoiding the taxonomical like general specific architecture that would that would seek
to find and relate identities, right? So in the the local example of the chapter of the series it's not
it's it's like not here's the identity of Carroll here's the identity of of Artaud and here's their
difference or in the case of the book overall here is my thesis on sense and then each chapter is going
going to incrementally build part of it and and that's right by the time you get to the end you
will see how all of this has been really just a way of showing what's at the beginning, right? But it's
like yeah each one of these is sort of like a thought experiment or a careful experimenting with or a line
of flight that sort of shoots off in this direction and then spawns or or um inspires another line of
flight that's going to traverse you know the same it's going to intersect that same first line and
it's going to potentially create things that look like paradoxes or contradictions or or redundancies
or whatever else and you can see that as sort of like him just not being systematic um or you could
see it as like these are intersecting lines that now lend nuance to like rather than seeing the paradox
as being like the not like as something that disrupts the body it's just it's constantly adding layers
of nuance which is why you can read them in any order. Yeah, it's it's totally like it's a meta move
like the whole book if if he if what he's claiming about sense is that it is both produced in that kind
of in the stating and the and the and the set in the saying, right? But that also that it provides the
Condition for that production then, you know, he you have to keep you have to keep trying it and reenacting
it and restaging it and redoing it and so each of the like little series are just like a here's that
here's another here's another and it's gonna, you know, it just continues to keep going. This is where
I remember when I wrote that, uh, the animal, there's an animal piece that I wrote a few years ago that
came out in P and R whatever you wanted to write but I I used the analysis of like that's right so
right, um but but I, in terms of the meta move, I was just like this is basically the dog winding
itself around a stop sign like the dog on the leash, right? that's just constantly like, you know, I mean
a dog on a leash that's sniffing around any sort of pole and it does not have that transcendent
relation, right? it just walks around and around all it's doing is sniffing similar spots but it just
winds itself around a pole and that's what our meta move is, right? like what or what rather what we call
a meta move is that we like to think of it as this sort of transcendent sort of looking down move but
we're just doing it at a different level than the dog is, right? like we're just winding around sniffing
around the territory come back to the old thing it's new and then we'll get started just like the dog
we're like why is that dog smelling that same rock that's right over again like well no it's a
different rock every time man yeah it's a different rock every time, right? there's a spiral dude
but it is what I mean also one of the things that is cool in terms of the Artaud is it really does give
you a sense of the fucking, you know, the the terror, right? like the the terror this is so there's a way
in which and I know I'm certainly guilty of this there's a way in which we can we attempt to kind
of romanticize becoming, right? and sort of say like hey man get on with the becoming train because this
being thing is an identity identity and is so old-fashioned it's like it's fucking it's terrifying
right it is you know our organism is not well equipped to to handle uh uh you know and our
brains are not this sort of transformative dimension of of I mean I'm calling it becoming
he doesn't use that terminology in here but events let's just say you know or sense it's not it's not
nice or friendly we could say so you know that's the schizophrenic is the body that lives the wisdom
of Silenus the you know what is the best for man that they never were born what is the second best
that they depart from this world is as quickly as possible like that launches for Nietzsche the
entire Apollonian move, right? yeah Dionysian yeah yeah I mean this is I think I think the impulse is
also to romanticize the body too, right? and and here we have a sense that you know the body is terrifying
or all body all bodies are really terrifying and this is where I really got a sense that
you know the body just as much as as language and the unconscious and thought like the body is
definitely part of that and um definitely inseparable during this event and that's terrifying
this is interesting because I found myself in in writing the topoi chapter for today so for the
recording I'm writing a chapter on on topoi for an undergraduate rhetoric course and I I mean as you
read Caddy like one of the things that I'm really interested in is or interested in trying to work through
for students is to see how um beliefs constitute communities and um and beliefs are sort of like you know
like a community maybe more or less sort of solidified based on the way that beliefs
circulate and sort of make it up and then as I'm trying and you know like the one of the first moves
I I say is like look we can't just think about the beliefs and in relationship to their sort of like
whether they're a fact or an opinion or whether they're just true or false we have to think about
them along this um a toxic and toxic uh um continuum where like some beliefs are still like solidly a
part of what it makes a community a community and other wines are you know increasingly idiosyncratic
from it and I say like but that's not enough there either because that presumes some kind of like
default community that you are that that sort of like stands in the center and everything is either
you know conforms with that or is um so then we have to think about all right there are multiple
communities and beliefs circulate across all like this whole multiplicity of uh um communities and
each of those communities themselves are are um uh you know more or less solidified and like the next
step that I have to to get to is to talk about how those communities themselves are not solid and they're
always performative are performatively that's right and they're and they're overlapping but then I have
to do it in such a way that we haven't looped all the way back around to the individualistic subjective
it's like some uh um uh fact opinion dichotomy which renders everybody you know just as an individual
and sort of like totally nullifies the idea of a community. I need to, like, introduce community and then
destabilize it enough, uh, to the point where we can't think of, like, where this isn't just about
stereotyping or stereotyping becomes a particular, you know, circulation of beliefs, um, but without coming
back to the individual, and and it's it's a maddening experience to to um, well, you have to, you have to
always been. I mean, that's that's to me where the thinking here of, you know, paradox is really really
useful because you have to go both directions at once, right? Like, you have to go in that case it's
not necessarily temporal; it's the social and individual, right? But you have to go both directions.
Like, you can't simply locate it in the individual or in the sort of pre-existing social, that there is no
right, and that that's like the cheese example that I use in in in the book, that the what is philosophy
right? Like, because it's it's the going from the general to the particular, the the deductive move
and then also the simultaneous, you know, inductive move that goes from the and that's so that sense
of like, you know, I mean, I would all like for for provocative reasons, I would take the more hard
line example and say communities do not pre-exist; it is the constant act of projection of the pre-existence
of a community, so that you know, but then you'd also have to say the same. Well, I think that's where I'm
going to end, right? I think that's where I want to get to. Yeah, at at the end. But what I what I was
thinking, I mean, talking about the madness there is that, like, actually thinking about the productive
value of asserting the individual and the community and that more reductive sense at first because it
introduces a kind of spacing into what is otherwise this amorphous, like, terror of being, and then you
know, like, all right, here's our spacing. Wait a second, you know, the relationship of the terms that that
spacing creates, they're super reductive, so let's complicate them, complicate them, complicate them
to the point where it's like, man, the value of the spacing has almost been lost because like
like uh like uh because though it never helped, but this suddenly got me thinking, like, what happens
when we start thinking about logic in general as just a particular meter or rhythm of spacing that is
interjected into like being or becoming that now creates interpretable, manageable, livable worlds, but
are also just totally arbitrary? That's that's that's Nietzsche, right? Like, I mean, that's the, you know,
that's how concepts are formed, right? Is this sort of rhythmic repetition of tropes in that sense, like
called truth or but I've never thought of that in terms of a spacing before, and I kind of want to stick
with that, yeah, with that metaphor horse, like, you know, I mean, I've, you know, we thought about in terms
of like, you know, calcifying concepts or so like through that repetition of like the repetition
of the lie that now you know takes the thing that is just purely sensory and it calcifies it into
something that is repeatable but not really sensory anymore in the same originary sense but like but
thinking about now spacing whereas it's not you don't start with the thing you start with the organizing
logic which then instantly creates a whole bevy of things and we already pre in relationship with each
other and I'm thinking about I'm now I'm thinking about Derrida and the importance of of the space
yeah difference that the becoming space of time and the becoming time of space. I mean, and he uses the
word spacing because I think what confused me is I thought you meant spacing simply in the spatial
sense but I mean you you actually also mean it's like the spacing of space. Yeah, right. That's right.
Right, right, the spacing of space, right, right, right, yeah, but that's it. I mean, honestly, I I mean, that's
where I like I I get that's fucking terrifying, right? Like, even to get close to that thinking
just makes me shudder, right? It really, it really does. I I feel like you were just celebrating that line
of thinking though. I mean, isn't isn't or like that kind of thinking is the one that's gonna distribute
openness rather than participate in like gap epistemology? Right? Rather than participate in
like trying to fill or something closed, you know? Yeah, I mean, that's the I mean, I think that is the
paradox, right? Is that there's and the the the I think the common response would be, and this is I don't
like this response but the common response would be finding a happy medium or finding a balance
right between the sort of disorder of of space and the the order of the the logic's intervention into
it and uh I I just don't like the thinking of the happy medium because it presumes the polls in advance
but but that is in fact what we're doing in terms of survival is always negotiating the tensions
between if you want to call it the Dionysian and Apollonian or order disorder order chaos, you know, like
those those sorts of things and which levels for instance I mean I think it's a perfectly valid
The way of understanding, as we all know, like when you really challenge a student's beliefs, that can be
really traumatic for them, and uh, we don't experience this traumatic because those are beliefs that we
gave up or that we don't find, you know, ourselves as committed to, but never, that just means that we're
playing a different, we're playing the same game on a different field, right? Um, so so it's always
the sort of relative negotiation of the, I mean that's where if you start talking about balancing
in the relative negotiation of the balance then it becomes a much more interesting diagram, right? It's
not just a question of we're trying to find the happy medium between these extremes, it's like
everyone's extremes are different and everyone's happy medium is different and now now you've got this
sort of oscillating, frankly you would have the series, it would look a lot like the diagram that
Nathaniel made, you know, several years ago, of like you have this oscillation among the among the various
series as a constant negotiation even though it would be between people, you know, in this regard
or between thoughts in this regard rather than between language and things or something like that
this is i think one of the things that why Capital, Why the Thousand Plateaus book appeals to me so much
more than the Anti-Oedipus book, and that's the reverse for most Deleuzes, like most Deleuzes really like
Anti-Oedipus, and you know, Capital Thousand Plateaus is kind of the the afterthought book, but I think the
difference there is that Thousand Plateaus they're much more sympathetic to not
de-territorializing, right? They're just like, you know, that whole de-territorializing thing, that all
those lines of flight, right? Those are fucking, those are, they really are terrifying, and that there's much
more of a sympathy for the molar or the, you know, whatever the terms may be, or even the trees in
terms of, I mean yes of course they're sort of go rhizome guys, but at the same time it's like but you
know becoming de-stratified isn't the worst thing that can happen to you actually, right? And and that's
where you know like becoming de-stratified, like or de-territorialization is
fucking death, and it's pure form. I mean that's what it is, and it's it's the end of yeah, and it's
it's an end of thinking, it's it's not, you know, so having finding those ways of of inhabiting a
kind of livable space is the is the the quote-unquote, I mean it's a different version of ethics, right? Like
not how do you live the good life, but how do you fucking live? Well another way of saying that
is that like for all of the the drive toward experimentation and creativity which is sort of like
the the function of life for for Deleuze, right? That happened in this livable space, from like here
to here and you know, like in the like in the direction of de-territorialization
like infinitely it's death, and in the direction of stratification and and the molar, like for
in like infinitely it's death, complete calcification or complete territorialization
complete de-territorialization, and it's like the whole move to experiment is sort of like
go from this tiny little space to like here
create that as your territory, de-territorialize and territorialize within that tiny little space
which is like far beyond most of our capacities to like that's that's life project for for most of us
well and it's like it's life's project, right? More more broadly, right? So it's like
hey, I mean you can look at it that way into the evolutionary sense, it's like hey
we need organisms in order to experiment experiment with the overcoming of organisms
how else how else do you do it, right? Like you know that you you're going to assume form content and
all of these sort of, I mean that's I feel like intellectually that's sort of where we are kind
of generationally is that there are all these sort of metaphysical concepts that we got from the Greeks
from you know 2,000 plus years ago and it doesn't take any more it doesn't take much labor to realize that
oh man woman those are pretty coarse grain concepts, right? Like nature culture, like they're just not very
dexter they just don't have the suppleness that's necessary and which is why you have non-binary
emerging as a category, you have all these other kinds of things this is like because the categories
just don't work the concepts that are organizing ways of thinking species to me is a big one, right?
like that that sort of that sort of thinking um it just doesn't they just don't work really well
anymore and yet you know and this is to me the Nietzschean call is like overcoming the human means
overcoming the conceptual organization so we're now at a point where like we're having to mess with the
concepts because not because we're desiring to be experimental thinkers but because they just don't
work anymore they just do not have the coherence that we have for a long time believed that they had
and that things are way more uh and it does seem this way things are just way more amorphous
and inadequately understood it's not it doesn't even take a brilliant rhetorician to read any kind
of analysis and be like well anything you know about contemporary politics or about flight it doesn't
matter what it's about and just be like well the kind of terrain in which they're attempting to understand
it another way of saying that is that like those categories like take the man woman category as as
like a tote boy for organizing a livable life and you can say like look for a few thousand years the like
that created livable a lot of like livable life for people right that that you know in the absence of
those categories would have been you know like far more difficult to manage and we could say perhaps
in some ways because of the success of the of that admittedly coarse um uh
uh category or differentiation you know like we're at a point now where that category that that
categorical differentiation actually causes more pain and suffering than it does create a livable life
and like so right well people start believing it but even go ahead continue no no continue i was going
to say like i mean you know like like the man woman category especially along this hierarchical order
like creates a certain kind of generational stability that provides roles for people to be able to sort
of create like you know and and that and it's always created suffering family always created suffering
particularly for like subordinated term right but it's also at the same time created a livable life
and because of the success of of that that binary it's now we're in a position where it's no longer
nearly as essential it's no longer nearly as important and in fact it does way more harm than
it creates way more suffering than it does we don't need it anymore to create this livable space anymore
and you know i think that's another way of saying what you're saying and it's and it's all and it's
all the categories just taking an example i mean now i'm back to my peter right now but back to my peter
watts conversation so it was one of those i was like look yeah the blind sight guy and we were having
this thing about um in in response to my virus piece and he's like and one of the targets there is the
the notion of mutation because when we and this is geneticists when they talk about
dna and rna replication right they always if it doesn't replicate exactly it's understood as an
error and i'm like why right like i mean so it get given that dna regularly does not replicate
you know identically how is it that we can come to understand it as an error well it's an error from
the point of view of species right from the perspective of a concept that the linnaean
concept that was invented 600 years ago of you know species that taxonomy and you just realize the
extent to which that taxonomy has just infiltrated the fundamental ways that we think 600 means
fundamentally go back to the primacy of the model to the copy right i mean that's all you need to
understand that's right you know why why genetic reproduction gets moralized right it's either
a faithful or unfaithful copy yeah and can't and yeah and can't but meaning there's no it's not like
i've got an alternate vocabulary where i can say okay let's not call this an error let's call it
a blah you know i mean there isn't just there aren't alternate categories for thinking i mean this is
this is the derrida problem right you can't step out of the language of metaphysics in order to undo the
language of metaphysics and so you are in this necessarily impossible situation of i don't want to
simply replicate i don't simply want to reproduce those concepts but i also can't you know critique
them from outside of them and that every critique reproduces them at the same time so how do you
invent and this is where you know de lewes talks about stuttering right that's the the later
terminologies making the language itself uh stutter which i think is a great to me that's a great way
like how do you make the concepts themselves stutter or the concepts themselves in other words they both
work and don't work at the same time and that's the strategy that this is what appeals to me about
all this line of thinking is that it's it's a tactical decision when faced with our concepts are
inadequate anymore okay so let's come up with another concept non-binary all right but
but that's not gonna fucking do it right like so you're either binary or non-binary right like so
binary or non-binary right so yeah and and it's not going to be long right politically before that
becomes a problem i mean it's just you don't have to know too much history to say every progressive
category has quickly become uh uh you know an oppressive category right like it's just that's how it works
You know, uh, so no, this is just go ahead, go ahead, this is really helping me understand what Deleuze was
doing by introducing Husserl's urdoxa, urdoxa, the urdoxa, right? Because I was kind of, I think I was texting
Nathaniel like, okay, so if we have this continuum of doxa from, you know, like the really idiosyncratic to
like the kind of wide, the more widely accepted or what have you, um, what, what's, what's the relationship
between, uh, beliefs, uh, the, the doxa that are beliefs and this urdoxa? And I wasn't thinking about
that. I wasn't thinking about concepts as things that people had to believe in as these kind of
transcendental independent principles for which you have to have in order to fucking think or do or
whatever, right? But it's totally the case that that that we have them and that they don't work, and then we
try again and we try to get another set of urdoxa. That's right, yeah, that's fascinating, yeah. And I and I
think that's his beef with Husserl, right? Is that he, Husserl's not actually able to play that game.
Right, that that Husserl, and I think I would argue that anyone who's trying to get it right
is not trying to play is not really playing the game, which is, I mean, he he articulates it as what
he says, like, Husserl can't get away from the common sense part, right? Like, it's just, it's just not, it's
not available to him, um, and that's what I mean is when I say, like, the ones who are trying to get it
right, there must be a different dispositional orientation towards the kind of questioning where
it's like Deleuze isn't trying to get it right, right? That's not the telos, it's not the goal, it's not the
hope, it's not the aspiration, you know? It's to produce something else and put it into play.
Um, which of course isn't right, you know? I mean, of course, it's it's not true or fault, but like
getting away from the problem of that true fall, you know, the the the the rule of the true false
you know, is is incredibly incredibly difficult, like it's not, it's always, it's not impossible because
I mean the the the allegiance to the right, right? I mean they go, yeah, I'm going to figure out what
this thing, I'm going to think through this problem. How do you, how do you begin that project
from saying, and I want to get it right? Because as soon as you're like, hey, I want to like deal with
something metaphysical or ontological and then you say, and I'm going to get it right, then you've
automatically created a more a prior, more transcendent, like, you know, like space from
which to measure the rightness of the thing. But if you were, you know, but if you have no idea what that
criteria is, right? Then you were sort of like just through a kind of endoxic, orthodoxic
iridoxic interjection, sort of presuming or assuming the metric by which you're going to judge the
correctness of the thing that you're diagnosing. It makes me think about how performative, you know? I
mean, measurement is just like that. We take measurement as such a natural thing and we forget about the
performative, institutionalized, um, uh, like, uh, uh, inter, interjection of measurement into life. Like, think
about, like, I mean, isn't there like a, uh, like a, a stick in Paris that's, you know, the literally the
measuring stick? Yeah, someone cut off someone's foot, you know? It's like, it's like the meters, that is,
this is the imperial system, the metrics, but there's like, was it the shoulder? It was whatever it was,
one of the kings back in the night in the 18th century. Well, that was in England and that's the
imperial system, where it's like, all right, all of these yarn, like, sellers are cheating each other by
you know, like, what's a yard or whatever? So this is a yard from here to here, that's a yard, right? And
you know, they took the measurement and that became the official thing, but you know, later with the metric
system, like, I mean, there's there's like, you know, it's far less attached to anatomy and like, you know, you
know, like an acre was the amount, was it an acre or a hundred? It's like how much you could plow in a
day, which obviously meant like if it was this, you know, if it was this kind of terrain, then you
know you could plow way more, but if it was rocky terrain, you can't plow all that much, which actually
had some, you know, practical like considerations because an acre is not an acre isn't an acre.
But um, it's actually linked to like what you use the thing for. But with the introduction of the metric
system, this is why I've actually found the imperial system to be so much more interesting because the
imperial system is so interwoven with, you know, human life and so its incongruities are sort of like,
you know, how much can I plow, how long is my foot, what is, you know, what's the problem with the tailors
trying to rip each other off with the metric system? It's the introduction of this transcendent
sort of like, you know, we're going to come up with an admittedly arbitrary, um, uh, set of rules, but like
we're going to treat them as if they're natural and like this is just, you need to, you need to write
This, you need to write this essay, and the title of it is, "Is man the measure of all things?"
You gotta get some protagonists in there, man.
But you're but you're right, I mean, and it is, I mean, just in terms of the development of something like
something as simple as measuring, I mean, I, when I, when you, when you're telling the story, when we're
thinking about the king, I'm like, that is the Nietzschean move, right? It's just like, and and I feel this
way all the time, not at the level, not at that level, but I I also am just like, okay, here's how
we're going to decide what a yard is. It's this end of conversation. It's arbitrary, right? It's like,
this is to solve a problem, and we need something that's right, right. This is it. Yeah, we need something
right here. It is, and this is, and so, and that's the legislative act that's, you know, we've talked
about this before, but all the times the analytic philosophers and the continental folks who read
Nietzsche, and they're like, how does he ground his truth claims? I'm like, how does he ground his truth
claims? He makes them. That's how it works, right? Like, he says, and here's what's true, right? That's how
you ground truth claims, right? Like, so that that's sort of, you know, the moral calculus that the analytic
folks do every time. It's like, what is the epistemological basis? And you're like, but what
world are you living in? Like, here's what makes it true. But that's that, like, that back to the
correctness thing. It's always the the presumption that there is the epistemological or ontological
outside that you can just simply appeal to to find this correctness without realizing that both of
those things, whether you're trying to go above or below, are also fabrications. But, well, so the that's
the thing about the meter, yeah, the meter isn't a given, right? And I mean, American history is a really
good example of that. I mean, I'm old enough to remember in the 70s when we actively, yeah, actively
try like there was during the Carter administration there was a concerted effort to switch to the metric
system and it completely fucking failed, right? Like, because you're like, yeah, I don't really need it.
It doesn't matter what I did, you're in the Brits, right? Exactly. It was, but I mean, whatever, it's like
but what that, what the sort of failure of the conversion shows you is that the metric is just another
arbitrary, and the problem the problem was, and this is the so sir problem, the metric couldn't solve
anything that the other one couldn't solve for most people in their day-to-day lives, right? So it's like,
I see no benefit to this. I see no added value. So why change this, this thing that I have for my life?
Well, Canada is an interesting case study in that because, you know, because they're they're like hip
and progressive, they did go with the metric system, but because they're not in Europe and they deal with
the US, they didn't totally go to the metric system, right? So we have kilometers and uh and and um
kilos and and and degrees of Celsius, but we also have pounds for some things, and we have, you know,
like and inches for others, and it depends on like what are you, in the medical profession, or are you a
butcher, or are you like driving a car, or are you a runner? So is it, is that, is that it? Is it, is that how
it, this thing is profession by profession? So like if you are, you know, like in medicine, yeah, but even
there they're not totally uniform, right? Because it has a whole lot to do with like are we, you know,
were these standards created by American organizations or by European organizations? So like Canada is this
weird, like it's a little bit of this, a little bit of that, in some places it's both. Um, and like I, it is
it is it is very odd. If I if I do write this, I think it's got to be for The New Yorker, and I think
it's called uh something to the effect of like I'm a liberal and I think that the imperial measurement
system is better than the metric system, right? I know I'm supposed to think as like the like the
lefty liberal I'm supposed to think this, but I think there's something wrong with it.
You're going to be strong in the capital any day now. I can see it. Well, you'll notice me by my sign.
It's a you know, like keep a foot a foot or make a foot a foot again, and then a picture of a big foot.
He calls it the impassibility of sense and the genetic quality, like the simultaneous
like it's not neutrality and uh generativity, right? Like the the um the two causes in this case being
right or that the the double causality being its relation, and I really like this and I haven't really
thought through this so if one of you guys can help me with this I would appreciate it, but like
um he's at pains to say the sense is an effect. It is an effect. It is not a cause, right? It is an
effect, and and I'm partly curious why he wants to push that so hard. Like I don't understand the
principle of logic that's at stake in that insistence because obviously what he's doing
Here is he's saying it's both right, which is to say it's an effect in relationship to bodies
and propositions um, but it's a cause in relation to other events, right? Other senses.
Right, quasi-quasi-cause, right? So it's again, you know, and I get that I get the dual, I mean what
he's trying to do there, but I I just was like especially earlier in the book when he said, like
it's an effect, you know, the senses uh, events are always effects, they're never causes um
I don't really understand what exactly is at stake there in in not, look, I mean I get that you want to
distinguish it from states of affairs, right, and and things and identities, and maybe that's it's that
simple is that if you call it an effect and you call it derivative and you call it secondary then you
can never be accused of what Derrida gets accused of with differance, right, that it's this generative
principle of of all things, right? So that he's like no no no it is not the generative principle of anything
at all ever except kind of right, but
also by the way this is maybe this is an aside that would be a different way like
so I I went back and read the uh um
uberscreen in berdeutung did you guys know of this essay? It's like apparently a really really really
important essay by uh what's one of the early analytic guys, late 19th century um
what's the was the English translation
uberscreen in berdeutung I don't even know I think it's just actually trans it's not the title
doesn't translate yeah it's on on sense on meaning and sense and and and I was reading it for my style
stuff right I wasn't reading it in relationship to this but you know sin is translated as sense and
but deutung is translated as meaning in German they both mean meaning right? Like that's what
people mean by you know you could use either word for meaning and the distinction that he's after
here and it's it's a really it's a it's a kind of esoteric logical distinction and what I'm about to say
is not correct meaning it's not an accurate reflection of this uh of this thing but I I got
the I got the impression Frega that Deleuze use of sense yeah Frega right it's Frega so this is all what
that's that's like late 19th century right? Or early it's old let's just say it's old aha see I didn't
make that shit up I like it when I happen to not make stuff up um but I really I was like I actually
think unmentioned that's what he's writing about right he's the the whole terminology of sense is coming
from the this Fregian this did this analytic distinction between meaning and in that case
again like sense means
all the problems with everything I'm about to say right like everything
right sense means something more like
connotation as opposed to denotation I mean that's now again those are that's not accurate and I know that
that that's not accurate because it has something to do with um almost like a set theory understanding
which is the coverage of all things versus the specificity of one thing but but that was that's
sort of my provisional takeaway and I was also looking for the origin of the distinction between
connotation and denotation because I'm trying like one of my arguments is it's an absolutely
bullshit distinction like it's an act like it's a completely anymore maybe it was functional at one
time but that whole difference between denotation and connotation is one I don't buy I just need to
let go of but for reasons that I think actually matter to my response here is that I mean from
a transcendent perspective I do buy that totally right like there's no such thing as denotation
everything is connotation but and in the same way there's there's no such thing as orthodox there's
only doxa and and and and right except for the fact that like there are you know authoritative
performative um um like we could say that there are certain kinds of like um authoritative performances
that assert orthodox and denotation so think about like you know the um the the a technical definition
for like the schematic of a rocket or sure or like the technical definition of transubstantiation
orthodox view of like the eucharist or something like that and so like while I would say at the level
of like some kind of transcendent meaning that's totally bullshit but in terms of like the force and
intensity that those that link those terms to those authorizing bodies and then link other certain like
bodies that we might say are part of those communities to them and sort of like can now
create the lay and the priestly classes of those worlds I say that absolutely does work but you have
To really think rethink what you mean by denotation
Well but you have I mean to me you have to say and you have to run this logic out the first step's
pretty easy. All denotation is provisional and and and singular meaning that I'm saying for the purposes
of this essay I'm going to define blank as blank, right? Like, so but okay, so that's easy enough to
understand when it's in you know your the the mechanical engineering essay or whatever else but but then
you say you know the same is true when the ruler says for the purposes of whatever my arm is going to be
in the yard and and so the the provisionality of it can be global, right? I mean it doesn't have to be
just this essay, it can be like for the purposes of living we're going to call these men and these
women, right? Um, so so the provisionality can have a really big I mean the provision could be life
itself, right? It doesn't have to simply be you know my little my little local thing but when when you do
that I think that once you install the notion of the provisionality of definition you eliminate the
transcendent function to me, right? Like, I mean that that's the purpose of calling it that so when once
you eliminate the transcendent function it doesn't matter how big the definition is, right? Whether it's
the OED or whether it's my paper it's you have you have gotten rid of the distinction between denotation
and connotation then because you've introduced the provision. Let's add to your cheese example because
I actually like to use I was still it's not mine from What Is Philosophy? I can't take I can't take
credit for it. When I when I teach students connotation and denotation I I usually sometimes
it's pizza or but like let's say you take cheese let's take Parmesan, right? And talk about the connotations
of Parmesan versus the denotation of Parmesan and now as soon as you talk about the denotation of
Parmesan you have to ask yourself what's denotating it, like is it like I mean is it this or that
dictionary or is it I mean I like to use old world foods because they have that's right there are
there are organized or there are legislating that legislating authorizing bodies that like define
Parmesan must be grown or must be made in in this Reggiano region with this yeah this procedure
has to have this percentage of milk fat to whatever else and then you get the stamp, right? But then we
obviously also yeah like Bordeaux like appellation whatever, right? So like all of these things but the
danger is to think that because those you know often we say like well it's the official or it's
the technical thing which we take as a transcendent function that's the real one and everything is a
derivation of it's like no it is it is one designation among others and it comes with a particular level of
like precision and it's tied up with sort of like you know you can be sued for selling Bordeaux that's
not you know from Bordeaux but that doesn't make it more or less transcendent, right? So that's it, so
that becomes the inter so that's the interesting question because it's almost like saying there is a
transcendent there's a transcendent there's a transcendence like function or quality that's
added to other things, right? Like that's added to so you know somebody says like this is Bordeaux
because it's from this region or this is what makes it Bordeaux and you know at the same time that you
you know you say that and you say it's provisional it's local it's whatever even if that locale is really
large at the same time it seems like it it takes on this other sort of larger transcendence it's almost
like this it's a side effect you know or its own kind of paradox in the very opposite way that Deleuze
is using paradox which is to say it's both transcendent and provisional, right? Like it becomes this thing
that is it's a it's a like an added quality so for instance the question would be could you make
a provisional statement that didn't have a transcendent function that did not like that
sort of prevented itself from rising above the circumstances of its inscription however big they
may be, right? They can be a nation, right? Like the nation will use this, right? Can you can you could
you remove this if I'm calling it a transcendent quality or the transcendent the function of transcendence
rather than because the function of transcendence seems to me that like kind of built in to every
provisional you know you just say for the purposes of these paper of this paper I will call this that
none of us argue about it because it's a paper but it is making a transcendent claim
yeah I mean it is creating a vertical relationship between the for the terms of this paper it's setting
out its domain that it is going to transcend above, right? I right which is why I always like this
it's the thing that appeals to me so much about Deleuze in terms of like cat uh terms like bodies
without organs and stuff like that where it it just fucking changes in the different articulations
Of bodies without organs in Deleuze's work, the the sense of it, the meaning of it in its most boring
way possible changes and without without him saying I'm using, I am now using bodies without organs
in a different way than I used bodies without organs in the last chapter, this is totally speculation
like a historical speculation but I feel like there, you know, there was an event in the history of Plato
and Europe, you know, would anyone recognize it as an event but like Plato in medieval Europe had like I
feel like there was some kind of conflation with the real and the officious and the sort of like the whole
divine, um, uh, right to rule thing where like the like states whether it was king or or pope or
or whatever it was were our incarnations or representations of the of the divine order
Right, yeah. And then so like, you know, think about just like in common parlance where we say like you
know, the official document is the real document, that's the real McCoy, is the real whatever, and we
know it obviously has this transcendent relationship but to me it's just like there's a sort of a historical
conflation between you know like an official designating body which we do as we teach us we
have to think about on a flat plane but we but it has gained a transcendent style force to it, yes
Right, yeah. Actually, this is I'm going to use this later because I don't know about you all as as people
who you know try to write theory or pretend to write theory but like I don't know if you get pushback
for a lack of signposting but next time I get next time I get pushback for a lack of signposting I'm
going to be like I'm just avoiding transcendence
I'm trying to create a transcendent free environment. I would appreciate it if you respect my boundaries.
No transcendence is good terms but I mean the other part is that you
the other part is that I mean the other part of it is that that's where I'm thinking like I mean my
initial thought when I was saying that was would there be some way to extract the quality of
transcendence from the legislative act, right, which is to say we're going to call this this but we're
going to always recognize that that's just what we're doing for provisional purposes, right, um, and
like could you call could you do that and then as I think about it I'm like no you can't extract that
because even the claim that we're only going to do this itself becomes a transcendent right like
in other words we're only going to use this in this in these particular circumstances well the the
designation of the particular circumstances the provisional is still a transcendent move, yeah
one must recognize, right, provisional is still transcendent and so at every step you take even the sort
of local legislation instantly has a transcendent function but this goes back to the vulnerability of
like careful diagnostic and the whole phenomenon to lose not renaming or re-signposting, you know
bodies without organs is that like I mean I think that that transcendent function can go away or become
not important when when you you allow the the terrain that it that it safeguards to be permeable and
vulnerable and open to like to yeah affectable shall we say, right, so even like so like you could never
say like no no no no no I was only being provisional because now you're trying to safeguard you know even
the very local context in which you've created that denotating things it always has to be the I welcome
it come on in and see you know why my provisional thing is gonna I know it's gonna change but I and I
can't protect it but now we've introduced layers of meaning and it really always does boil down to style doesn't it
it you